[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Kitty ko sushi in Los Angeles where
I'm joined by one of Southern
California's biggest most unrepentant
sushi snobs Andy Milonakis I feel bad
so many people love sushi and I try to
bite my tongue when people are like yeah
I love sushi and then they start talking
about it and within the first two
sentences I know I'm like not real sushi
some of my friends called candy sushi
which is just like rolls and tempura
flakes and eel sauce and spicy
mayonnaise and all the like Americanized
[ __ ] what is it about sushi
specifically that gets your juices
flowing sushi is a vacation for the
mouth no no to me just raw seafood in
general is like the best food on the
planet like to me not there's nothing
like tastier than some good raw fish
well we're here at Kitty ko sushi we're
here to learn from one of the best sushi
masters in the game chef Ken Namba and
we're going to be trying out the omakase
menu which is a service that is just up
to the chef it's very much a dealer's
choice chef special baby but first to
the kitchen was an awkward transition so
we can figure out what the hell reading
this is make it awkward whoo
my name is Ken Namba I am the ownership
of the chemical sushi in heart of West
Los Angeles I was born in TG raised in
skeezy the Tsukiji market is the biggest
fish market in a world and the most
interesting fish place in the world no
doubt I started my career when I was 17
worked in the very famous master chef
this master chef
he was already over 70 but one of the
fastest best hands I've ever seen myself
I'm over 60 but I'm still learning
that's the only way that tomorrow is the
better oh my gosh
means ships menu just picks the best of
the day for song tonight so Mikasa is
the adventure he will never forget for
rest of his life
I'm not really a seafood guy ha - I'm
scared - [ __ ] I mean I want to show you
so she's gonna show me really for real I
like it yeah I like to just sit back and
then just whatever comes I'll just take
it down you know yeah I'll remember that
next time we hang out and we're not
shooting okay today's sushi obokata
I start with the bluefin tuna tuna is
the big animal
right after you catch you try to eat is
too hard
so we have to age tuna for probably
seven days or more to settle the flavor
and tender the meat I think that's the
biggest misconception - is like the
freshest the better kill it slice it
either that's everybody says that to
know is that the fresher is when you'd
like it that's when you need it but no
no cheers Cheers
lights you up a little bit hmm
hobby that's what I like I think she is
you get that wasabi burn in your nose a
little bit certain things that I learned
that were like mistakes that a lot of
people take wasabi and mix it in with
the soy sauce technically not supposed
to do that I'm not going to like nitpick
every little thing they do because I
feel like that's an [ __ ] move right
but when you're going to save them from
ruining their meal then all then I'll
chime it up it is red snapper
yes it's one of my heroes no so I
thought there's the rule there's the
rule it's really got a really layered
piece of sushi right number one thing
that I see people do wrong with nigiri
they take it and they dip the rice side
down in the soy sauce and it becomes a
complete salt bomb and you wash away all
the flavors of the fish when you do use
soy sauce it was like flip the fish and
kind of dip it like that so you just dip
the fish and got to go fish first on
that yeah gotta go fish look at this you
got it or else you just soak the whole
block of rice and then you're just like
those a nice $12 bite of salt you know
when you think about sushi
I think about hand rolls I think about
rolls but what are we eating today we're
eating Alma Giri anytime you see like a
rectangular block of rice with like a
slab of fish over it
that's nigiri sushi me is just usually
pretty thinly slices of fish lightly
seasons and then sushi rolls kind of
like rolled up in the seaweed cut into
pieces sometimes people complain that
sushi is not filling enough at the end
of the meal you get a hand roll and that
punches you and you're like whoa okay
now I'm done
very true I try to give you a tour Oh
next one did you want auto Rose no very
fatty one or two total margin after the
cheaters okay I always hear people
talking about sort of this Toro that you
have even the difference
Oh Toro has a chance of being ten out of
ten more than tutorial but to Toro is
definitely more consistent that way
you're going to be an eight year really
good yeah
guarantees eight so this is a tutorial
is the medium fatty yeah recipe so far I
think
yeah you know why cuz I don't even think
I used my teeth on that yeah like I just
took my tongue pushed it to the top of
my mouth that it was just gone
turning me on oh I'm doing the sear the
Goldeneye snapper the Kimia died oh my
god this is really really good it's
better lukewarm so that generates more
flavor and then chef I noticed you know
we're going with our fingers on this one
is it when do you use chopsticks when do
you just go fingers though I have no
rules about that I mean like a you know
people not used to that picking up the
arrow fish with your own hand and go
ahead use the chopsticks
this one looks serious little any times
for me this one really you what is the
sauce of the fish I think it's the way
that they both take when you see some of
the fish with the darker scale usually
they kind of have like a deeper ocean
flavor I think it just sees like the sea
just doesn't he's like a stank mermaid
so this is the last one it's serious
business over here what do I do is just
family it's just kind of like a little
ice-cream cone you can chomp ah ah ah I
got because I must cheers man truth in
real ha ha ha it's great yeah so is this
your first Oh Mikasa first omakase ever
what are your final thoughts this was an
amazing meal after a meal like that you
kind of lose yourself in the experience
and that's like one of my favorite
things about sushi yeah and that's the
thing you know uh I eat three meals a
day every single day how many of them do
I remember like a nun it's gonna be a
long time before I forget this girl yeah
so we're supposed to kiss now that's not
happening
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] it Yolo